Is "Renfield" going to get your blood
pounding when it drops in theaters on
April 14? Or does it just suck? Here's what the
critics think about the upcoming horror-comedy.
Nicolas Cage is returning to
the big screen this month as
one of the most iconic fictional
characters of all time: Dracula.
The Oscar winner stars alongside Nicolas Hoult
in "Renfield," the new film from "The Tomorrow
War" director Chris McKay. Based on an original
idea by "Walking Dead" creator Robert Kirkman,
the film follows Hoult's Renfield, the longtime
henchman of Cage's Dracula, as he tries to start
a new life for himself away from his bloodthirsty
boss. As its tongue-in-cheek premise suggests,
the first "Renfield" trailers have sold the film
as a bloody but lighthearted horror comedy that,
perhaps more than anything else, will give Cage
the chance to chew up the scenery once again.
Now, ahead of the film's forthcoming April
14 release, the first reviews for "Renfield"
are starting to roll in. While an overall
critical consensus has yet to be cemented,
the early buzz for "Renfield" seems to be
mostly positive right now. That isn't to
say that the early reviews for the film have been
overwhelmingly glowing. As is usually the case,
some critics have taken to "Renfield" far
more easily than others. Consequence critic
Liz Shannon Miller, for instance, gave the
film a B+ score in their review, writing,
"'Renfield' knows exactly what it wants
to achieve and does so effectively."
Miller isn't the only critic that enjoyed
"Renfield." In fact, of the film's first 25
Rotten Tomatoes reviews as of the making of this
video, only five are negative. While each critic
has offered their own takeaways from the new
horror comedy, those who enjoyed "Renfield" have
repeatedly emphasized the film's combination
of gory violence and chaotic sense of humor.
Maggie Boccella praised the film's horror-comedy
tone in their review for Collider, noting that
it has more in common with genre classics like
1981's "An American Werewolf in London" than
it does any of its scarier vampire movie
predecessors. Boccella went on to write,
"Ultimately ['Renfield' is] fun primarily because
it doesn't commit too hard to any one thing."
Moviegoers will likely be delighted to hear that,
in addition to the film's comic horror spirit,
Nicolas Cage's performance as Dracula
has been heavily praised. Indeed,
the trailers that have been released for
"Renfield" have all suggested that Cage's
performance in it will be one of his
most unabashedly over-the-top in years,
and it sounds like the actor has
more than delivered on that front.
"I am dracula."
In their review of the film for The Playlist,
Matthew Monagle specifically praised the actor's
turn as fiction's most iconic vampire, writing,
"In Nicolas Cage's hands,
Dracula is the perfect marriage between
the rock star and the jilted lover."
"Exactly, he won't grow to full power. What?
That's so weird. Why would
you phrase it like that?"
As noted previously, the early reviews for
"Renfield" haven't been totally positive. A
handful of critics have, in particular,
criticized the film for apparently
failing to explore its story as much as it
potentially could have. The Seattle Times'
Moira MacDonald said as much in their
negative review of "Renfield," noting,
"Even with its brief running time, the
movie runs out of steam too quickly."
Elsewhere, Variety critic
Owen Gleiberman took issue
with the thinness of the film's script, writing,
"It's a scattershot lark jam-packed with
'ideas,' none of which really take hold."
Even some of the positive reviews for "Renfield"
have lamented the lightweight nature of the film.
In their ScullyVision review, Dan Scully
gave the horror comedy a fresh rating on
Rotten Tomatoes but was also quick to note that
it doesn't quite live up to its own promise.
"['Renfield'] proves to be a broadly
pleasing, remarkably safe studio comedy.
This isn't necessarily a bad thing so much
as it's a case of squandered potential."
With all this in mind, it seems safe to
say that "Renfield" delivers an enjoyable,
if not necessarily outstanding,
experience at the movie theater.
"Focus on your needs."
Thanks to its mid-April release date,
the film should, in other words,
offer interested viewers a refreshingly
R-rated, bloodsoaked counter to "The
Super Mario Bros.," which has taken the
moviegoing world by storm this month.